welcome to this video playing jammie
Dodger info for once I'm playing white
we have a kind of a thematic tournament
and then the cocom not this time
probably we'll get the tirage or the
Catalan let's see what is playing now
okay we get it to rush a three this is a
pretty good line
III some one of them one of the rather
new developments in the towers
just yeah well okay this should be
useful in most cases I'm just a swan
you want ideas to use the bishop won't
be to where it is so nicely placed some
other terrorist lines you you have it on
III which isn't so bad as well
controlling the d4 square but okay b2 is
just a nice place for this piece Medina
was not a four to c5 but there's also a
bit of a decentralizing booth so maybe
black has some way to to count it
Black is always suffering a bit with
this isolated poem which is really a bit
of a weakness but the good thing from
blacks point of view is you have all
your pieces out you don't suffer from a
structurally bad piece like it sometimes
happens and in some classical Queen's
Gambit swear you have a bad bishop on c8
sitting all the time in some other
defense where you have a piece that is a
constant very this is not the case here
the worst that can happen is you you you
lose support on d5 which is pretty bad
if it happens but it's still it's just a
pawn and doesn't mean you're
substantially worse GTG came okay
I'm 94 so good centralizing move what
I'm wondering is should I play it looks
like rook e1 to cover - this is so good
strategical move but maybe f2 is a
weakness yeah cannot spend so much time
glad to have a slight edge on the clock
and don't want to invest
so much time now yeah with nightly fire
also controlled the c5 square which is
of course helpful because 94 to c5 was
an important idea yeah
what I'm wondering is if I play Knight
c3 what is he playing just taking it out
let's try this text e5 and it tends to
take him for if he drops back to f6 I'm
playing G 45 & Windus pawn and yeah but
what I'm doing now g4 and g5 this is
just winning upon yeah I can play 25 25
mmm does he have some compensation maybe
you can go Bishop d6 know that I think
of it what this exam could be a move
yeah we should be six but what am i
playing on that petechiae also possible
of course might be five intending queen
bee 5 and 10 in 95 maybe is he actually
threatening something but yet I have
queen bee 5 still maybe is threatening
to take him
Paige rabbit I can just take f2 there's
nothing okay let's not spend spend ages
here he has some compensation anyway and
it's hard to to judge what's the best
defense the computation is and in those
slightly exposed pawns my king is
potentially insecure I'm at the moment
he doesn't have any pieces near the king
so I don't think it is this one 925 and
to f4 why not
the other night therefore I thought
would be would be nicely placed
but I actually go with their we're not
just this one night of six am i because
of that I can take me seven though yes
sir it's the big attacker coming and
maybe my cannot really cover this side
can I'm a Quincy for maybe why not why
not just Quincy for
maybe just going just going for Queen G
for Bishop d6 is not not threatening
that much actually or is it this is here
this is a check it is not more than a
check
check I'm covering each one
mm-hmm ah Cindy Mary singing to lower
that check check check
time warning check check
have an idea what the clock is yeah I
can't play on actually because of the
position - looks are better than the
Queen yeah it's really no need to draw
check check check
check great yeah yeah you're great play
on Queen g7s really deservedly winning
the game yeah I was just too too clumsy
with the mouse and there were six
seconds against two seconds but okay I
didn't it's in play play much the last
couple of days the trustee may be okay
man
yeah well anyway around here around here
this is rather complicated I mean yes
it's it's complicated in a blitz game
like it's mostly just a pawn down but
around here yeah our night F for us
actually strong here okay but this is
not realistic to find all this with a
little time yeah why just keeping a
clear edge anyway done 97 is better okay
willing okay I only saw that and this
leads to a somewhat better hand game for
white simply because the two looks are
stronger than the Queen that's probably
a drawer somewhere with with perpetual
here why this is better simply okay he
only won this game because of my moving
speed this is this is lost now for black
with two rooks on the seventh okay
thanks for watching